The 1995 movie The Net is a paranoid thriller
about this oddity called the internet.
“Our whole world is sitting there on a
computer, it’s in the computer.”
Sandra Bullock’s character chats with Cyberbob,
orders her pizza off Pizza.net,
and hangs out with Dennis Miller during that
brief window when he was a feature film actor.
“This is, this is bizarre.”
As an early cyber thriller, The Net introduced
the internet and, as importantly, a
“look” for the internet to a lot of people.
But those webpages weren’t real. Someone
had to get those invented graphics on Sandra
Bullock’s computer screen.
“My name’s Todd Marks, I’m a computer
video playback
supervisor for feature film, television, and
commercials.
I’ve been doing this for about 25 years
now.”
Todd’s work shows the incredible detail
that goes into major motion pictures, and
reveals secrets behind the screens within
screens in movies from
The Net to
Steve Jobs.
But it also uncovers a key to how big stories
are told well.
A computer playback supervisor gets the
graphics on the screens in TV shows or movies.
Sometimes the screens you see in movies are
added after the fact, and sometimes they’re
prepared beforehand to shoot along with the
scene. People like Todd have to figure out
how to display and make those graphics. Well,
as Todd explains:
“Well, the challenges of doing any production
graphics, motion graphics, or playback
graphics for a film is to do something that’s
visually interesting, conveys the message,
and is plausible — those are my three big
things.”
In the comedy Anchorman II, challenges common
to Todd’s job are especially clear.
The comedy’s set in the early 1980s at the
dawn of cable.
“We’re starting a 24 hour news channel.
GNN, the global news network.”
“That is without a doubt the dumbest thing
I’ve ever heard.”
That meant there were tons of old TVs in the
background — each of which had to be period
appropriate physically and display something
period appropriate, too.
They filmed a lot of the footage on their
own, because the easiest way to get something
that looked like it was from the 80s was to
make it.
“OK, what’s gonna go on this screen, what’s
gonna go on that screen, and what’s happening...
Will Ferrell is coming into the studio, so
we’re not on air yet. What’s on the screens
then?”
In this case, Todd had to plan — a lot.
This chart is typical of how a playback supervisor
would need to plan for a busy shoot. It breaks
down the necessary shots.
Ron smokes crack on air? There’s a neatly
ordered cell in the spreadsheet to get everything
necessary for the shot.
Other documents carry more specifics. When
Ron and the team meet their new co-worker,
Linda Jackson,
Todd had a list of exactly what background
elements were necessary, like the three wall
TVs.
That planning allows big gags to work without
a hitch.
When idiot weatherman Brick, played by Steve
Carrell, went in front of a green screen in
green pants, it was clear the scene would
work better if Todd and his team made the
effect happen live.
“It wasn’t that tricky. But the production
hadn’t really planned on doing it live,
and we were like, no, we’re doing this live,
and they were like, ‘Oh, great.’”
The result of all that is
“AAAHHHHH.”
In Team America, planning meant finding the
perfect tiny LCD screens for Kim Jong Il’s
palace.
“The smaller scale there’s little 7 inch
screens right there, 7.5 inch screens, and
you can see me, I had to like
lean in without falling into the set.”
In the comedy, The Internship, which was set
at Google, it meant finding the right giant
screens for corporate presentations.
But these screens aren’t only important
details. Sometimes, they can be a key turning
point for a story.
“With Date Night, in that particular scene
with Mark Wahlberg, he was
a high tech security expert.”
Now you might not expect Date Night to include
a technically driven moment. It’’s a very
light 2010 comedy.
But Todd’s work in this scene is crucial
to landing one of the movie’s best jokes.
In it, Mark Wahlberg parodies a trope of over-the-top
action movie computer stuff. It ends up being
pretty funny — and that joke required a
lot of work.
“Sp then we have to create a whole logic
to the thing and kind of map out what we want
to do.”
One silly gag required elaborate mockups,
rejected concepts,
and designs to perfectly sync the digitally
inserted screen
with the practical side units on the wall.
You might not be looking for a coherent user
interface design in Date Night. But see how
they bothered with the color of that circular
control? The filmmakers cared because it was
key to making the joke work.
That attention to design was important in
a different way in the period piece Steve
Jobs,
which was about design, computers, and presentation
— basically everything someone like Todd
cares about.
“As far as the challenges, there were so
many challenges
involved in that project.”
Challenges like making computers from 1984
look new again.
“You could put the old Macs apart and put
this paste on them, and leave them out in
the sun and bleach the plastics.”
...Or finding the perfect build of blueberry
iMac. These details were key to making the
movie — and the movie’s emotions — feel
real.
One of the most touching scenes in the movie
is when Steve Jobs connects with his daughter
over a new computer. The character is normally
distant, but he’s able to be more open and
warm because of software. And in the movie,
they didn’t fake it.
“That was a Macintosh, and that was a special
one. John, our engineer, had actually built
a special video card for that one.”
“Push that key and the S at the same time.”
“And we had to load everything off of floppies.”
“Now type your name.”
“The artwork was created by our artist in
Photoshop, so now we had to figure out how
to get this Photoshop file back down to a
400k floppy.”
“Do you know which box is save?”
“it was really booting off the real Macintosh
software. You know, it’s craziness!”
“If there’s something that the actor can
act against, it’s much better...it’s better
for the director, it’s better for timing
when things are cued and when people can respond.
It’s better for the editors, because they
have something to edit against, versus trying
to cut to something that’s not there. It
just makes the whole process smoother, even
if there’s something that needs to be changed
later and they have to burn it in later, which
sometimes happens.”
That makes it worth the difficulty and the
stress, worth doing live instead of after
the fact.
The gimmick in The Net was
a hidden backdoor that basically unlocks the
internet.
“You click on the little Pi symbol while
you’re holding this key, and then you get
into that, which again was pretty ridiculous
— at least it moved the story forward and
didn’t pull you out.”
The idea’s implausible, but kind of compelling:
there is a whole world, tucked in the bottom
right of a screen somewhere, hiding in plain
view.
That’s how movies build worlds. With obsessed
over details that make it easier to produce
and see emotion, because there aren’t any
distractions. Because the world feels real.
To see it, you have to take the time to
search for it.
“This picture is of when I worked on Star
Trek Nemesis. And that’s the little ship,
the plaques they have on the bridge, and it
has a lot of names of people who worked on
the movie, so I’m in there.”